Traduttore: Asia Carafa
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Che cosa resta dell'umano?
Che cosa significa
"rimanere esseri umani"?
E che cosa significa vivere
o non vivere in una dimensione
che è tra le due classiche distinzioni
della riflessione scientifica,
filosofica e culturale dell'occidente.
Cioè la natura e la cultura,
ormai superate sicuramente,
ma ancora oggetto delle due principali
famiglie di discipline scientifiche.
E che cosa significa questo
nell'età cibernetica,
cioè nell'età dominata
da quella scienza nocchiera
che Norbert Wiener, il suo fondatore,
aveva definito "La scienza del controllo
e della comunicazione
nell'animale e nella macchina".
Se consideriamo che animale
significa qualcosa di animato
e la macchina, "machina" dal latino,
è un congegno che si muove nel mondo,
forse possiamo iniziare a capire
ciò a cui mi riferisco.
E adesso, proprio perchè sarà
un pendolo continuo fra le scienze dure
e le scienze morbide, vi invito a tenere
nella memoria dell'immaginario
questa immagine.
Ѐ tratta da un film, "Ex Machina", di cui
non vi farò lo spoiler naturalmente,
ma che ci fa già vedere una creatura
artificiale, chiaramente macchinica
con tratti femminili che si confronta
attraverso un vetro con un essere umano
in carne ed ossa di genere maschile.
E questo significa già essere in
un setting di un test particolare
di cui parleremo.
E tenendo questa immagine
possiamo dire cosa resta dell'umano
nell'età cibernetica, accorpando
il titolo e il sottotitolo
quando, tenendo appunto questo
aspetto sullo sfondo possiamo dire
fino a che punto possiamo venire
modificati dalle tecnologie
rimanendo 'umani/e'?
E non potrò darvi risposte,
solo porre alcune basi
a loro volta articolate al loro interno.
E la grande riflessione di oggi
si muove, o diciamo, è innervata
da queste due coppie di concetti:
postumano come condizione,
transumano come condizione
alternativa
e le rispettive filosofie:
Postumanesimo e Transumanesimo.
E queste due coppie in ogni caso
si confrontano con la relazione
fra umano e macchinico, o "machinico"
se vogliamo lasciare l'origine latina.
E si arriverà per gradi alla fine
a questa riflessione,
passando per esperienze,
cognizioni ed emozioni
che sicuramente ci caratterizzano
come umani.
Quindi ripensare all'umano significa
anche utilizzare da un lato
tutto quello che la cultura alta e bassa,
le immagini fisse e in movimento
dell'immaginario globale,
dai romanzi, ai comics,
ai manga, agli anime [giapponesi]
in una visione anche interculturale,
ci permette di capire questa realtà
sui generis
che è la realtà sociale della cultura,
e che direi che nessun altro meglio
di un grande scrittore e teorico
come Philip Dick ha chiamato:
"La realtà è quella che rimane quando
abbiamo smesso di crederci".
E questa realtà sui generis della cultura
e della società ci può aiutare a capire,
a decifrare con le funzioni
dell'immaginario alcuni aspetti
di questa trasmigrazione.
Adesso passiamo al polo delle scienze
e vediamo come gli stessi acronimi,
cioè quei nomi che contengono
tutte le iniziali dei significati
che le contengono,
addirituura nelle scienze della vita
ma anche nella bionica,
in particolare nelle pratiche
riabilitative prostetiche,
dimostrano che esiste una necessità
già all'interno delle scienze dure
di una fortissima apertura
interdisciplinare.
Proprio perchè gli aspetti dell'umano
che vengono curati, riabilitati,
potenziati, come vedete spaziano
da genetica, robotica,
information technology, nanotechnology
oppure nanotechnology, biotechnology,
information technology,
congnitive science.
Quindi vediamo che la sfaccettatura
di questa apertura di nuove dimensioni
sia vista già dalle scienze che sono ormai
parte della nostra realtà quotidiana.
E quindi tornando col pendolo
dalla parte dell'immaginario
questi nuovi ambiti, ripeto, di cura,
riabilitazione, potenziamento,
che ci aprono le scienze, come stanno
invece con quei sogni e gli incubi
dell'immaginario fantascientifico
in cui il non morto, ciò che non vive
e non è nato e tutta la fantasmagorica
classificazione dei non nati da donna
come il grande visionario ingenere
Tagliasco, prendendo da Shakespeare,
aveva chiamato.
Tutta quella serie di creature artificiali
o ibride, che continuano ad animare
o ad inquietare i nostri sogni
e i nostri incubi,
partendo dai Golem, dal più antico
antropoide tellurico artificiale.
Fino appunto ai Cyborgs, ai Replicanti
e agli Androidi Ginoidi.
E come influenzano queste figurazioni
l'idea che abbiamo di ciò che è umano?
E soprattutto l'idea di come
ci dobbiamo comportare?
Perchè le machine, che sono senzienti,
calcolanti, irreagenti, sono lo specchio
della nostra umanità oggi,
e ci pongono questioni etiche
e pragmatiche fondamentali.
Per cui ritorniamo alla nostra Ginoide.
Quindi vi ho detto che l'androide
femminile si chiama Ginoide
e in questo caso è una creatura
molto curiosa, una scienziata
che ha rovesciato e trasformato
il setting: The Turing Test.
Perchè come vedete è lei
che interroga l'umano
e soprattutto in totale trasparenza.
Non vi è più possibilità
di essere ingannati:
il punto è domandarsi
che cosa significa essere umano,
se io mi considero non ancora
abbastanza umana, perchè in questo plot,
in questa trama, vedremo
che la Ginoide arriva ad avere caratteri
sempre più femminili e sempre più
mimetici durante tutto il percorso.
Ma l'interrogativo che ci pone
è di questo tipo:
che cosa vuol dire essere umano?
Non vi è niente di più umano
della volontà di sopravvivere,
di vivere degnamente.
Oppure queste due proposizioni
le possiamo considerare
sicuramente ancora coordinate
ma disgiuntive?
Quindi la prima opzione "Non vi è
niente di più umano della volontà
di sopravvivere" non ci riporta
alle origini che ci legano a tutti
gli esseri animati e che quindi
ci riconducano ad una visione
darwiniana, evoluzionistica, conflittuale
della relazione fra le specie
e fra ciò che è umano
e fra ciò che non lo è?
Non è piuttosto la volontà
di vivere degnamente
quello che ci rende umani e che quindi
permette anche a noi di fare un salto
nell'apprendimento etico?
Diventare meglio di ciò che siamo
senza necessariamente avere bisogno
di una rinascita morale del genere umano.
Semplicemente mettere a frutto
le potenzialità e le risorse etiche
che già possediamo.
E quindi le nuove sfide
di una bio-robotica
o diciamo etica, o diciamo pure
di una robo-etica,
possono essere di nuovo
espresse in domande.
Essere umano significa essere puro
dal punto di vista
della limpieza de sangre
cioè vuol dire essere nato o nata
da donna, secondo i metodi naturali
oppure essere umano equivale
a possedere ed esercitare l'abilità
di essere responsabile, di fare scelte
e di assumersi la responsabilità
di tali scelte?
E quindi, queste nuove creature
fanno già parte,
anche se in forma di esperimento mentale,
nella nuova frontiera dell'etica?
Naturalmente io rispondo con un "no"
alla prima domanda
ma rispondo un "si" a tutte le altre.
E quale sarebbe la soluzione?
Dal punto di vista umano potremmo
riformulare l'imperativo etico di Kant,
adeguandolo alla nuova relazione
con gli esseri ibridi ed artificiali
e dire appunto che essere umano
vuol dire: agisci in modo
da trattare tutti questi esseri machinari
o machinici, almeno in via di principio,
non soltanto come strumenti,
non soltanto come mezzi ma anche come fili
dentro un orizzonte intra-mondano,
dentro una dimensione più inclusiva
e non più antropocentrica.
Dal punto di vista invece della machina,
Ex Machina, potremmo vedere
che potremmo francamente riprendere
la legge zero di Isaac Asimov,
un grande scienziato
e scrittore di fantascienza
che chiama con la Legge Zero
una massima fondamentale:
un Robot, ossia un'intelligenza,
una creatura capace di sentire, rispondere
e di agire nel mondo, non deve recare
in nessun modo danno all'essere umano
nè permettere per omissione che venga
arrecato danno ad esso.
E quindi ritorniamo,
con un'accentuazione positiva,
sulla slide che parlava
di Postumano, Postumanesimo,
contrapposto al Transumano
e al Transumanesimo.
Perchè? Perchè soltanto la legge zero
ci permette di fare una cosa fondamentale,
cioè di togliere l'etichetta
di mostruosità
o di essere fonte di repulsione
a tutto ciò che non è biologicamente puro
e ci mette al sicuro dal ritorno
strisciante del razzismo
e della volontà di discriminazione
nei confronti di nuove entità.
Ci riporta di nuovo al dilemma
di dover rifuggire dal razzismo
in quanto un male latente
nella nostra condizione umana.
Postumano ci permette di connettere
il passato, il presente e il futuro;
perchè di radici del postumano
ne abbiamo trovate: dal Golem
fino ai Cyborgs, in tutte le culture
anche non occidentali,
facendo riferimento anche a quelle
forme di sapienza e di conoscenza
che sono l'animismo, lo scintoismo e tutte
le altre riflessioni non monoteistiche,
oppure accanto a quelle monoteistiche,
che permettono
di aprire una via all'inclusione
di tutti gli esseri viventi e non viventi,
umani e non umani, fino addirittura
ad includere la dimensione
della materialità nel suo
più ampio complesso.
Quindi il Postumanesimo è
la corrispondente concezione
di una costellazione, di una condizione
che può essere considerata
in un passato carico di futuro.
A differenza di questo,
il Transumano è una condizione
anch'essa definita dal Transumanesimo,
tramite l'ideale definitivo ed ultimo
del mind uploading,
dello scaricamento della mente
e quindi dell'abbandono del corpo,
della radicale smaterializzazione.
Se vogliamo un futuro
di pura razionalità,
in cui le relazioni saranno
soltanto fra puri esseri immateriali,
abbandonando la grande dimensione
che ci fa non solo essere umani
ma ci fa esseri relazionali,
perchè senza il corpo, senza
la fondamentale definizione dell'orientamento
nel tempo e nello spazio e dell'assunzione
di responsabilità che la corporeità,
di qualunque tipo essa sia,
ci dà, perdiamo moltissimo.
E se ricordiamo di nuovo le scienze
di cui io ho parlato, il GRIN [ICT]
o le altre tipologie di connubi
interdisciplinari
di scienze che si occupano di cura,
riabilitazione, potenziamento,
quando ci spostiamo sul potenziamento
vediamo che le nuove discipline
fanno capire
che non potremo mai eliminare
la vulnerabilità
non solo perchè è inevitabile
che noi saremo costretti a dover
riconfigurare nuove vulnerabilità,
come l'esempio del tallone di Achille
ci ricorda,
ma anche perchè la vulnerabilità
è anche una dimensione di apertura,
di nuova possibilità, di nuovi futuri.
E di nuovo, il Postumano come condizione
e il Postumanesimo
come riflessione filosofica,
ci avverte anche di un'altra cosa,
che non ci sono futuri scritti.
Vi sono tante possibili configurazioni
di questa nuova dimensione
e soprattutto ci invita a non cadere
nella trappola del dualismo
tra ottimisti o pessimisti.
I technophiliacs e invece
i nemici della tecnologia.
In realtà siamo in una serie
di tradizioni nascoste
che ci rendono possibili nuovi futuri.
Vi faccio ancora due esempi.
Uno da Minority Report, in cui vedete
che è possibile avere versioni diverse
per impercettibili elementi del futuro
che quindi si realizzerà diversamente,
e anche le scienze ci dicono
che la più perfetta equazione
cambia di risultati
nel momento in cui si
modifichino anche di un micron
le condizioni di partenza.
Quindi possibili futuri alternativi
ci sono davanti,
andiamo oltre il determinismo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)